hi mystery recap here today i'm going to
explain an american science fiction
thriller film called the signal
spoilers ahead
watch out and take care
the movie starts as we see a man named
nick who suffers from some kind of
muscular dystrophy
nikki's with his girlfriend haley and
their best friend jonah in a car driving
to california
the boys are dropping off hayley who is
moving to california for further studies
the three were all classmates at mit
before this
a montage of the trio traveling follows
they eat at diners visit aquariums we
also see nick jogging to a river that
has swiped away a path
the trio is staying in a hotel room for
the night nick cannot seem to fall
asleep when he suddenly gets a text from
a man named nomad
nomad is an anonymous hacker who has
been texting nick and jonah for a long
time
he once hacked into mit server as nick
and jonah and almost got them expelled
he has been troubling them ever since
when nick threatens to expose him for
hacking into mit nomad sends him a live
video of themselves in the exact
position they are in he had hacked
haley's laptop in the background and is
watching them through its webcam nick
then takes it upon himself to find
nomads location and eventually finds out
that nomad is texting them from nevada
they continue the journey from the
following day
on their way jonah receives a picture of
their car from nomad
the three are tense about the situation
jonah in the back seat actively tries to
find nomads exact location they stop at
a gas station and nick gets out to get
them coffee haley takes this opportunity
to ask jonah if nick has said anything
about her moving to him
she knows that her decision to move to
california has bothered nick but is
worried because he hasn't said anything
about it yet
nick falls and drops the coffee on
himself while the other two run to help
him he is embarrassed about his
disability and it is evident when he
walks away to get more coffee visibly
sad
the boys have found nomads location and
figured that he is only 180 miles away
from them they have decided to pay him a
visit on their way but when they look
around they see that haley is missing
nick finds her sitting on a cliff nearby
the two finally talk about their
relationship
nick doesn't want his disability to hold
her back so he wants to break up before
she leaves
haley tries to convince him that it will
work out when he doesn't listen she
takes off the necklace he had given her
as a gift and throws it away the trio
then makes their way to nomad's location
they stop at an abandoned house at night
but they are skeptical about nomad's
presence at such a place but the boys go
into check anyway
they look around with their flashlight
but do not find anything
suddenly they hear hayley scream outside
and run to her
when they get to the car she is missing
and the car's radio is glitching the
guys start to panic and scream her name
just then nick flashes his light in a
direction and sees hayley being pulled
to the sky by a weird force
frightened they run towards her calling
her name the screen abruptly goes blank
when nick wakes up he is in a
hospital-like facility wearing only a
hospital gown and is still hazy a man in
a white space suit like a tire brings
him to a room in a wheelchair
another man in the same attire
introduces himself as dr wallace damon
he starts to record their conversation
and asks him about the first time he
encountered this signal nick has no idea
what he is talking about
he asks damon about his friends and why
he is here damon replies that nick and
his friends have come in contact with an
ebay an extraterrestrial biological
entity nick is still clueless as to what
he is talking about and demands to meet
his friends or call his family damon
stops nick from talking when he sees
nick's nose starting to bleed heavily he
is then taken back to the room he was
kept in before
the following day the facility workers
take him to the same room again on his
way he sees the workers cleaning a
strange liquid on the facility's floor
then he sees haley lying in a room
he demands the workers take him to her
but they do not agree
he is taken to damon who says that he
cannot meet haley at the moment and
starts asking him a series of strange
questions like if he has ten toes and if
he is from the earth damon then asks him
about the signals referring to nomad's
texts
finally he shows him a clip from the
night they were at nomads he zooms into
an alien figure in the background which
nick is surprised to see
to his horror damon reveals that nomad
was not just some hacker
sometime later nick is back in his room
when he hears someone whisper to him he
looks around the room and figures the
noise is coming from a vent
it is jonah hiding from the workers to
come to talk to nick
he acknowledges that something is
severely wrong with the people there and
fears they might be performing
experiments on them the conversation
ends abruptly the following day nick is
with damon again who this time is
performing a shape and color test on him
agitated nick solves the test in one go
and demands to see hilly damon agrees
and takes him to the room where haley
lies unconscious he claims that she is
in a coma and promises the second she
gains her consciousness he will be able
to speak to her from the next day nick
starts devising a plan to escape the
facility he crushes the cracker given to
him as food and places it under the
keypad to figure out the password
combination of the entrance door
when he is back in his room he puts his
plan into action
he goes to take hayley and ties her bed
to his wheelchair meanwhile damon goes
to his room and finds drawings of the
facility all over his bed they get to
know about his plan
nick somehow manages to get himself and
hayley to the exit door but he cannot
reach the keypad nick tries his best and
even uses the hospital tube to press in
the keys
however demon catches him before he can
he wakes up next to haley who is still
unconscious while trying to free from
the guards he falls off the bed the men
leave when they see him bleeding then
nick is horrified to see his legs have
been amputated and replaced by
prostheses made from alien technology
damon who has been watching him through
a one-way mirror tells him that it is
difficult to explain
he then sends two workers to get nick
but his new legs have superhuman
strength
using them nick sends the door flying
he drags hayley out with him as it seems
that he can finally walk now
as he walks through the hallway with her
damon follows them and catches them at
the elevator
he calmly explains to nick that he will
only be able to help him inside the
facility and if he goes out he is on his
own
nick ignores him and runs away with
haley he ends up in a dimly lit hallway
and then in a sewer-like system
when he finally sees sunlight he finds
himself in a desert in the middle of
nowhere
haley finally wakes up and the two start
to walk away after a while they are
delighted to see a car coming towards
them and ask for a ride the driver is an
old delirious woman named mirabelle
throughout the journey she acts strange
talking to tiny angels that she claims
are sent by god
she drops them off at a gas station
nick goes in and tries to use a phone
but it doesn't work he sees his face on
the news on the tv but just then nick
sees a red truck take hayley away
using his new legs nick runs as fast as
the truck
haley points a gun she found in the car
at the man trying to kidnap her the two
throw the man out and drive his truck
away
meanwhile damon sets a roadblock to look
for the two and finds mirabelle he asks
her to come with him and she agrees
damon also carries a mysterious red
briefcase in his hands he interrogates
her at the facility but strangely
mirabelle's nose starts to bleed like
nix did earlier damon brings out a gun
from the briefcase and the screen goes
black implying that he shot her dead
nick and hayley on the other hand reach
a dead end and have no clue where they
are
when they drive back they find an
abandoned visitor center they decide to
stay there for the time being
inside nick tries to use a phone but it
doesn't work either haley then finds a
map of the place however nick cannot
decipher where they are
damon and his men continue with their
pursuit and find hayley's abductor in
his home he seems to have gone insane
and talks about his family sitting
beside him when he is alone he points a
gun at damon but it doesn't work when he
tries to shoot him damon then shoots the
man dead covers him with a blanket and
leaves
meanwhile nick and hayley hear a noise
from downstairs and hide
they come across a worker from the
facility but it turns out that it is
jonah the friends finally reunite and
share their experiences it turns out he
also escaped from the facility at night
nick notices a mark on haley's back and
believes that she has been experimented
upon too
later jonah tells him that they might be
in area 51 and we get to see that his
arms have been changed into prostheses
the following day they drive in search
of an exit but are caught in a roadblock
jonah attacks a guard and fires some
rounds using his gun while nick and
haley crouched down by the truck
soon jonette is severely wounded he
tells nick to take haley and go while he
distracts the guards nick doesn't want
to leave his best friend but has no
other way
jonah uses his new arms to destroy a
cylinder blocking the truck and the
other two run away
he then punches the ground creating a
shockwave that shakes the guards he dies
in the encounter but it all goes in vain
as nick and hayley are soon caught by
damon their truck hits a spike line on
the road and flips over
the two come out of it but are severely
injured haley hands nick the necklace
that he thought she had thrown away the
guards take haley away in a chopper
after she is gone nick notices damon's
name tag and figures that his name
backwards is nomad damon comes clean and
says that he has been nomad the whole
time
he had brought nick to them posing as
nomad to test alien technology on him he
then claims that his legs are examples
of a perfect combination of human and
alien technology
realizing that they were used as mere
experiments nick is agitated his legs
start to glow red and he runs at
supersonic speed
after a while he crashes into an
invisible barrier that leads him to a
larger exterior facility damon
approaches the hole he has created in
the environment and takes off his suit
to reveal a robotic head as it turns out
he and everyone else in the facility are
a robotic alien species
mirabelle and the kidnapper were
abducted humans who were driven insane
because their brains couldn't sync with
the alien technology since they could
not adapt to it damon had to kill them
when nick turns around he sees that he
is on a whole new planet the desert was
just a simulation to trick them into
thinking they were still on earth the
camera finally zooms out and we see that
the planet is highly modernized with
several skyscrapers and has a parabolic
sun shield on the top
nick is the only human there his best
friend is dead and his girlfriend has
been taken away from him subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching